when Jeffrey and I were starting we we
took a slightly academic view one day
and said what's your prediction about
the approach they're going to take are
they going to go more for story are they
gonna go more for character and we found
out the answer is neither they went for
conflict and so if you were to give us a
premise to develop the very first step
we would take is okay whatever the
premise is where do we get conflict out
of it okay if there are two characters
involved how can we make them butt heads
to do something because everything would
come out of that
for character and I talked about this in
my Pixar seminar so because they masters
of this you know they tell stories about
toys about monsters about bugs about
robots right you know fish rat
they make you care and connect with
those characters so there's there's a
whole bunch of techniques and and you
can see what they do and you can know
what the techniques are for me it's like
there's three three things that you do
that I that you do is is make us make us
feel sorry for that character so there's
a little moments where you can you can
create a moment in the story where a
character is unjustly abused or unjustly
mistreated or insulted or betrayed or
neglected and so it could be any
character and if that moment is there
you know feel sorry for that character
at that moment takes an instant so
that's one if you show that they're like
us if we show their humanity for example
your show that they care about something
other than themselves that's another
technique so there's a moment in the
movie Leon the professional which is
about a hitman right and it opens with
him doing a hit and he kills people you
don't know if he's good or bad but he
goes home and he takes care of a plant
right and that's right away you say oh
he cares about a plant so he's okay he's
human
the other part is admiration so this is
like any any kind of you know if you're
dating somebody or you're trying to find
somebody who's a good match for you
there's that list of lists of things
that you like in a person that's
admirable trait so somebody was funny
who's responsible who's courageous
there's a whole list of things you can
add to a character to make us say oh
well you know I admire this usually
they're like the best at what they do
they're like the best you know the best
at executive or the best agent the best
cop the best driver
they're courageous there's a whole bunch
of a moment have a hope the list the
list is all in the book there's all
these lists of things you can do but if
you do these three things and I saw when
I show clips of the of the moment you
meet the character and usually I look at
three minutes scene you can see all
these things being applied in like three
minutes there's like you know the the
opening of wall-e after he's done with
the garbage in comes to us to his little
house it's a three minute scene and it's
about twenty of these techniques done
this is how you connect with that
character in one scene emotionally I
also show a clip of a of an ad the
commercial it's a one minute thing about
a lamp whether it's a great ad for IKEA
award-winning commercial where they make
you carry mostly for the lamp right and
and the the joke about is that the guy
comes on says you know you probably had
feeling for these lamps that bit that's
because you're crazy the lamp has it's
only a lamp it's you know and the new
one is better you know the new lamp to
replace it so but anyway but it's great
it's amazing once you once you know
those techniques and then you see him in
action you got my conned you know and
now and I kind of always feel I was give
this caveat with to my students and to
anybody who hears me speak that if you
love stories if you love films and you
don't want me to destroy the illusion do
not listen to me because I feel like I'm
one of the magician's who would give you
the trick of how it's done and you then
you see the trick and it's not the same
anymore so I always felt bad about that
because you know once you know the
techniques and you see a film you're
gonna see him everywhere all the time
and it's gonna kind of ruin it for you
so just fair warning right there that
you know those are those are this is how
we do it and that creates that effect
you know
it's not an audience's or a readers job
to feel something that's something new
you have to elicit so it means you
haven't created sufficient conflict in
your story to elicit emotion or you
haven't created a premise a concept of a
story you haven't structured in such a
way that that conflict makes any sense
or it can be emotionally involving
because you've given the reader nothing
to root for or you haven't created
empathy with the hero or whatever it
might be but it's your job to elicit
emotion the emotion has to come
naturally from the reader an audience
because of what they're what you've done
they have to be participating in the
story you've created that's why for
example empathy is so important for the
hero for you to create for your hero
because a story is a participatory
experience for the audience of a
listener of the reader we become that
character we want to experience the
emotion as they do it's not we don't go
to the movies because it's interesting
to watch people do things it's emotional
for us to get to do them we become Jason
Bourne we become rose as she falls in
love with Jack and is on the Titanic we
become the woman who the astronaut who's
out in space in gravity we are a part of
it we're participating in the action in
the events of that story but we have no
basis no way to get into the story
if we don't on a subconscious level
become the hero of that story and that's
what the empathy and identification you
create at the beginning is going to do
so if you've created a story with an
empathetic heroes that we participate
given them a clear goal and created
enough logical believable obstacles to
overcome then the emotion will grow
organically out of your audience because
they're in it and you've created the
conflict that will do that to me all
roads lead to the outer motivation and
so if all you're doing is stringing
together obstacles to overcome and
there's a very similar mistake and that
is people who think calm
is one funny thing after another
happening that's not what that's not
what a story is a story is the sequence
of events experienced by a hero who's
pursuing a very specific goal so if
you're just throwing one obstacle after
another but we don't care about the hero
or the hero it's not clear why the hero
is doing this or what they're trying to
achieve or if those obstacles are
illogical or if the pace of the story
lags or if everything is at a very high
level of emotion and you're not creating
sort of peaks and valleys to the
emotional level so you have big moments
in quiet moments and moments of
connection and moments of separation and
so on there are all those things you've
got to do in addition to throwing a
bunch of you know car chases and fight
scenes up on the screen which many
people have tried and those movies don't
succeed if if it's just car chases and
fight scenes it's just you know it's
just a series of videos really but it's
not a story or a movie that are people
are going to be involved in well it has
to alternate yeah it's it's not a
resting point as if you stay there
forever but you don't it's like in a
comedy you don't want a joke joke joke
joke joke there's got to be a serious
moment or two and and look at any great
comedy look at it even any decent comedy
and there's going to be something very
funny but there's going to be something
touching or sad or romantic or there's
going to be a deeper connection between
the characters or there's going to be
something more exciting or there's going
to be something softer you want to vary
the peaks and valleys the emotional
level and and pitch of the story as we
go steadily toward the finish line that
the hero is trying to reach so the
obstacles need to get bigger they need
to come closer together as it moves
forward so the pace will accelerate but
if there's only obstacles one right
after the other with no chance to catch
our breath no chance to anticipate what
might be coming no chance to explain
what's going on and no chance to get
closer or deeper into the characters
it's going to be a ver
very shallow story with very limited
emotional involvement or appeal
my process evolves every time I do
another job I realized how much I didn't
know and my prior job so it's it's I'm
somebody who reads pretty much every
trick every screenwriting book every
script that I could get my hands on and
I'm constantly trying to evolve as a
craftsman
I also am fortunate enough in this job
to surround myself with really talented
people and and you learn a lot from
other writers like there were writers on
on man in the high castle who won Emmys
or you know Martin Scorsese's best
friend is another one like like you you
want to really kind of learn from from
the people around you and that just
makes you better so I can't say that I
have any set process although right now
as I'm developing something I have to
say I'm a big fan of the john troubie
john troubie stuff I think he kind of
hits a sweet spot for me but you know
I've taken them all taking McKee taking
everything I'm one of these guys who it
likes to learn new stuff about the craft
and I figure if I can learn something
from any book if I get one thing out of
it makes me a better writer that's kind
of I'm all for it I am more of a planner
than a pan-cancer like you know
obviously like Stephen King will say
swears by the seat of your pants
approach but I'm much more of a
an outliner and engineer when it comes
to that and then you throw that out and
then you and then you let the character
speak to you and you get in the moment
and things change but but I also I'm a
big fan of structure I have to say so no
I haven't just sat down and tried to
write something a final product from
page one I kind of construct it over
time I'm a grinder I guess you could say
a common notion particularly about
action heroes the notion was always in
the past that when you have an action
hero or especially a superhero that you
want a character who begins as a good
person an upstanding moral Paragon and
remains that way throughout the entire
story but about 10 years ago
Hollywood discovered that that's not the
best way to tell a superhero story
that's one of those examples of
conventional wisdom that's not so what
we care about is to see a character
overcome a deep weakness now the
audience thinks that this story is all
about the hero achieving his goal right
because then we've got success and
that's important and in most stories the
hero will accomplish his goal by the end
of the story but that is not what the
audience is most interested in they
can't tell you this but we know from
lots of experience hundreds of years of
storytelling
that the cave the real fact is not does
the hero accomplish the goal but does
the hero overcome the great weakness
because that's what makes us care about
that character we see them in pain we
see them in trouble right if they're
already successful if they're already a
good and in some cases a perfect person
where do they go right there's nothing
for them to overcome so that's why it's
so important that we show in the very
opening pages of our script the great
internal weakness of our character now
we may also want to give them qualities
that are likable qualities that the
audience can also hook on to but those
are not nearly as important as
establishing the weakness upfront in the
store
most overrated part of the screenplay
equation is the idea ideas are really
pretty useless and worthless again
[Music]
give me a repeating myself but I am a
one of those people who believes that
Breaking Bad is one of the greatest
achievements in the history of
civilization I think it's really great
great drama so what's the idea that
drives it a high school chemistry
teacher gets a cancer diagnosis and so
he decides to go into the
methamphetamine trade with an
incorrigible former student of his a
criminal you know to sell drugs to
support his family that is the stupidest
idea I've ever heard many many companies
shot that down and yet it is this
triumphant achievement 62 hours of a TV
series every frame of which is engaging
and and and captivating and involving
and the so how did that happen the
answer is they told a good story it's
where the story it's really all about
story that's what we believed at UCLA
that's that's what I believe a few years
I mean imagine if somebody came up to
you and and said I have an idea for a
movie
this guy's stutters but he has to give a
speech so he hires a speech therapist
they work on the speech he gives a
speech at the end of the movie if
somebody told you that that's gonna win
the Oscar for Best Picture and Best
Screenplay you figure they're crazy and
yet that is of course the King's Speech
and again I think it just demonstrates
the the value of story and the value
lessness of ideas and I think that the
very young people are more into ideas
they have great ideas I like to say when
you have a great idea if you have a
really really great idea for a
screenplay that's all you've got I think
what remains after that everything the
characters have to be invented the
dialogue they speak
has to be created it has to be punchy
and peppy and provocative and pungent
I'm just getting into peas now and
poetic and it has to be worth listening
to or for itself just because there's
something kind of charming about it but
beyond that it can't be just for itself
it also has to advance the story in a
palpable measurable identifiable way
likewise expand the audience's
appreciation of the characters it takes
time for me to give you an idea about a
movie I can you know takes a handful of
seconds to walk you through the story of
the movie who takes to the length of the
movie a couple of hours so that's where
the value is
the suspense is the anticipation of
action it's not action itself the minute
you have action the suspense is gone but
what you want to do is create suspense
in ways and actually be anything that
can be something blowing up you know we
the the joke I was talking about in
class was the red LED bombs that the
bombs that have the countdown on it
that's you can only read if you're going
to be blown up because like no you know
no one's gonna stand there close to the
bomb
but as they countdown that's that
creates the suspense and that suspense
can be anything from notorious has a
bucket of champagne bottles at a party
and as the champagne bottles get pulled
out and people are drinking and drinking
and drinking then finally we get to the
point where there's no more champagne
bottles somebody has to go to the wine
cellar and that's where Cary Grant Angra
Bergman are poking around because they
believe that the bad guys are doing
something that's hidden in that wine
cellar
so the suspense is will they run out of
champagne before they find the evidence
and get out of there and because that's
a cool movie doesn't quite work out the
way they planned and they get caught you
don't want to jump straight to the
action what you want to do is you want
to create the suspense the anticipation
because that the Hitchcock said that you
can have a bomb under a table and it
explodes and it's surprising and you
have like maybe five seconds of the
audience going oh my god a bomb exploded
or you can put the bomb into the table
the audience sees the bomb and then you
have the two guys have a conversation
about anything the weather sports scores
and the audience is going don't you stop
talking about sports scores there's a
bomb under the table it's gonna kill you
you know you've got to do something
about it and that's what creates the
suspense so what you want to do is
figure out the ways to draw things out
and I mentioned the class a crappy movie
called flesh + blood where one of the
characters is going to this trying to
poison somebody with their with their
water and so they take the pitcher of
water and they put poison in it and what
happens is then that character they're
trying to kill takes the water and pours
it into other people's glasses and
you're going you can't do that you can't
do that you're gonna kill innocent
people and then pours the water to his
glass and as he pours the water in his
glass gets ready to take a drink and
then somebody says something to him and
he stops and has a conversation with the
glass
so close to him drinking it and if that
guy who drinks it first and dies then
the person who poisoned it can tell
everybody else not to drink their water
so it builds suspense in two ways that
way the if somebody else drinks first
they've killed an innocent person if
this guy continues this conversation for
too long those people are going to drink
first it's going to be over usually what
happens is they don't try to draw it out
they don't tell they don't suspense is
based around dramatic irony where the
audience knows something that the
characters do not and often what happens
is they don't tell the audience so the
audience has no idea that the glass of
water is poisoned or whatever and so
when the person drinks that they they
die and you there's no suspense there
suspense is telling the audience ahead
of time what's going on so the audience
knows that the characters don't and that
ends up being the big issue sometimes
with suspense that doesn't work
subtext generated in probably two ways
one is if this topic of your scene is
why are you cheating on me as it
sometimes is say with harsh and Carol
you have them talk about anything but
that in a way and in a context so harsh
and Carol talking about their marriage
whilst to res is in the other room and
overhearing things you do it in that way
you you go off point of a conversation
you have a conversation about how
difficult it is to repair the damn
plumbing or whatever but and you do that
in order to make your point very clear
which is dammit this is this is wrong
all of this is wrong and the other way
which is really a one of my favorite
ways is to just describe behavior in a
certain context so Carolyn Torres riding
in a car what is she looking at what is
she doing what is this what's what's
actually going on and none of it has
anything to do with oh I don't know
camera angles or anything like that it's
just about what's happening which is the
basis of all drama whether it's a
screenplay or or play how people inhabit
a space at a certain time that's it
it seems almost laughably simple or easy
but it rarely makes it intact to a
screen in the way that that this has
enhanced greatly by the muse own sin and
and and the performances and everybody
in every department just working to a
preserve a fundamental truth about a
piece of material
Beetlejuice for instance the idea was
that I discussed with my partners a
psychedelic ghost comedy we had no idea
what that meant but it rolled off the
tongue right and and and and I usually
have something of an idea like that and
I kind of know the beginning and I kind
of know the end the middle is the great
unknown but but but but it's it's an
instinct and an idea and sometimes it's
a character and sometimes it's a
situation but it's very it's very
internal at first and and and yes
there's times where you write an
assignment you know and and and you're
you're you're given an idea and say
translate this into a movie but in terms
of my my own my own writing if you will
my my personal writing it usually comes
from front from just the most basic kind
of idea and a feeling you know and and
it's like and I can't articulate it very
well I'm sorry because it's hard to
articulate but it's just kind of like
again light like a situation and our
character that's just kind of waiting to
come out and then you whatever you
whatever your process is and boy do you
need a process and boy do you need to go
to work and boy do you need to sit down
and do it and do the job of writing and
and and you allow that that character of
that situation to just start growing and
sort start coming you know leaving your
fingers on to the digital page these
days you know on your computer and then
it grows and expands and it takes on
life and and you know I there's of
course and this is that this is every
writers choice there's a lot of talk
about back story always you know like
like tell it you know where did your
character go to school how you know
we're
what was his or her mommy like and all
of that I've never written a back story
in my life never but if you ask me to
tell me the back story of one of my
characters I could I'd kind of be making
it up as I went along but the feelings
would be true because I feel I I feel
the characters and I and and I feel like
they need to come out and I feel like
they need to be given a voice and and
that's just that that that's that's what
writing is to me a a an idea or a
character or situation or an emotion or
a feeling that that that you somehow
have to put into the world and it's hard
to articulate and I feel like I'm
talking in circles but I but it's it's
just it's almost hard not to because
it's so it's so in the beginning you
know I I hope that makes some version of
sense
by setting aside
to an event just like we took medicine
earlier at is an invented the light bulb
you have to invent the stuff that he
does and says you have to invent the
situations he's a handyman never really
had a really steady job he goes to one
particular house and that maybe he's
having trouble getting getting work and
he goes to one particular job and
there's a woman there who tries to
seduce him and so on now what I just
said I don't mean to suggest that that's
genius out of out of Shakespeare but it
is events and anecdotes and I'm
inventing the one of the best movies
ever made is is double-indemnity and
when I was just describing sort of
sounds like ol indemnity I mean first of
all it how'd you like to make a movie
about an insurance salesman that's not
gonna excite a lot of people yeah that's
what double indemnity is about so it's
the stuff that they do and as you
remember if you if you're seeing the
movie if you're having you gotta see it
it's just a one of the great great great
films he's going out to the to try to
sell an insurance policy at one of those
mansions in my neighborhood Los Feliz
silver legless Feliz he says it's one of
those thirty five thousand dollar
mansions I mean you know this is
nineteen forty eight or whatever it is
I mean thirty that's not even a fraction
of the Commission for the realtor you
know these days and then he meets this
woman there and it's so strange what
she's doing and that she's very
seductive just like we were describing
about our handyman but the point is it's
the action it's when it's the actions
that characters take that define their
character there's a wonderful book very
underappreciated by a writer who died a
few years ago it's called plots and
characters and by the way plots is first
not by accident and also in Aristotle's
Poetics the first book on dramatic
writing he clearly says plot is what's
really important not character because
again character flows out of plot there
isn't any
character outside of a plot and if
there's a plot is automatically
characters that are that are going to be
in it so once again I just can't hammer
enough on how amateurs feel the taunts
don't get that then it's really about
story and that what you the real work of
a writer is inventing the actions
milord Couchman is the name of the
writer who wrote the book plots and
characters and he has one of the most
timeless brilliant lines in it that I've
ever heard him here it is I've already
said it which is that it is action that
defines character and not the other way
around I'm gonna say it again
it's action that defines character and
not the other way around people who
think it's the other way around are the
kind of people who are doing these
character workshops will invent this a
character who has all these traits and
qualities and characteristics and then
we'll turn or loose and see what she
does know define what she does tell us
what does she do and that'll tell us who
she is that's true in your dramatic
narrative that you write for the screen
it's also true in your life isn't it I
mean I like to think that I'm a moral
principled reliable decent person but I
look back at what I've done in my life
and I see shortchanging myself and
others disappointing myself and others
constantly frequently acting out of fear
I would say my actions defy means a
little bit of a coward I'm easily I'm
afraid of a lot of things it's not the
way I want to be but again it's what I
do
to the actions the events the incidents
the anecdotes in my life that tell me
who I am and that tell anybody who who
they are
um that tell audiences in movies in
movie theaters looking at the screen
that's what tells them who those
characters are Tony Soprano is a
function of what he does he's a vicious
murderer criminal he's also a father and
a husband he's also a troubled man who's
having blackouts fainting spells and
these he's worried he has so worried
that he does a really worse wimpish
thing which is engages a psychiatrist
you know a therapist a woman on top of
that I mean a mobster a made man and the
mob doesn't do that and all of those
things define for us who who he is again
it's not like we've defined the
character and then put them into the
situation's we put in the situations and
then the situation's define the
character